faut-il avoir peur d intelligence
artificielle je pense que c'est une
question qu'on me pose souvent et sur
laquelle on me dit beaucoup de comment
est ce que je devrais communiqué est ce
que j'aurai davantage faire peur à ce
que voudraient davantage faire moins
peur et je pense que c'est une question
également très intéressant très
fascinant qui m'a mené à pama réfléchir
et pour nous aider à mieux réfléchir je
vous propose d'écouter ce petit extrait
de radio lab si jeune
[Musique]
m
dancing bad things that people
il existe dans des marques apicole
m'agace à l'ana
[Musique]
et donc en réfléchissant un peu plus à
cet extrait et à d'autres d'autres
aspects des enseignants'' artificiel ça
m'a mené un peu à la conclusion suivante
qui est que plus globalement fait même
la notion de faire peur aux gens
ça va pas être une fin en soi le but
c'est de ne pas avoir peur si on se fait
peur aux gens c'est dans le but qu'ils
se préparent à des risques éventuels
en tout cas c'est tellement c'est
exactement comme ça que je vois le la
raison d'être de la peur pour vis-à-vis
des intelligences artificielles
il me semble qu'il ya des gens qui est
effectivement n'ont pas assez peur des
risques de l'intelligence artificielle
comme peut-être par exemple cette
chercheuse qui a été interviewé et colin
moore il semble qu'il ya vraiment des
raisons d'avoir peur des nantais ans
artificiel pour nous préparer à des
bouleversements qu'elle annonce en
termes par exemple de 10 paye comme ça à
quelqu'un dans cet extrait en terme par
exemple aussi de suppression des job
parce qu'il ya clairement beaucoup de
jobs qui vont être complètement au moins
bouleversé par l'émergence de techniques
technologies d'information de façon
générale et dans un silence
artificielles en particulier
et puis moi personnellement ben le truc
qui me fait le plus peur dans le sens où
ça attire le plus mon attention et sur
ce que je pense qu'il faudrait qu'on ait
beaucoup plus de moyens pour préparer
l'avenir
ce sont tous les systèmes de
recommandations des réseaux sociaux avec
toutes sortes de risques associés mais
aussi d'opportunités notamment par
exemple en terme de polarisation en
termes d'addiction ou encore en termes
de prolifération des messages de haine
et du coup si vous êtes quelqu'un qui
notamment peut faire quelque chose par
rapport à tout ça il n'avait jamais
pensé à ça bien j'ai envie de dire que
c'est peut-être sans doute utile d'avoir
un peu plus un sentiment de peur
vis-à-vis de tout ça en tout cas si elle
vous permet de mobiliser un peu plus
votre attention et votre énergie pour
essayer de préparer le futur de tout
cela des dix pays qu du marché du
travail et j'ai système de
recommandations mais à l'envers ça j'ai
envie de dire si vous êtes quelqu'un qui
a vraiment peur d intelligence
artificielle de base et en particulier
qui a peur pour des mauvaises raisons
par exemple à cause d' image terminator
j'ai envie de dire que la peur dans ce
genre de situation en particulier si
c'est ou fait soit si vous paralyse ce
soit sous fait paniquer à ce moment là
je me dire que la peur est un mauvais
sentiments pour vous puisque ça vous
empêche de vous préparer adéquatement
pour le futur et en particulier sur la
foi paralysie et le risque de panique et
de prise de précis de décision
précipitée il ya un vrai risque et pour
éviter des paralysies beaucoup trop
importantes qui peuvent conduire des
inactions au moment où il faut prendre
des actions ou pire encore des mauvaises
décisions
6 a précipité un peu vos décisions c'est
au conduit à de mauvaises décisions
à ce moment j'ai envie de dire éviter
d'avoir peur si la peur vous empêchent
de bien réfléchir à éviter d'avoir peur
si et de vous calmer et de voir présent
toutes les opportunités qu'offrent les
intelligences artificielles et toute la
motivation qui peut avoir à réfléchir à
ces questions assez fantastique
bref essayer de gens me dire choisir vos
émotions pour préparer vous préparez
vous votre entourage mais également ce
possible nos sociétés à des
bouleversements à venir qu'annonce
toutes sortes de nouvelles technologies
en particulier les intelligences
artificielles
je rajouterais que l'on agit pas tous de
la même manière à la peur pour certains
d'entre nous la peur est quelque chose
qui va vraiment nous motive et nous
amener à faire faire des choses et pour
d'autres parmi nous la peur est plutôt
quelque chose qui ne nous fait pas
vraiment agir ou stress un petit peu
trop ils nous empêchent première votre
meilleur travail et dans ce cas c'est
peut-être mieux de plutôt se concentrer
sur des aspects motivant ou des
opportunités par exemple si pour ça que
c'est aussi important de parler des
risques de liam est également de parler
des nombreuses opportunités qu'il ya à
rendre les ja robustement bénéfique et a
fait en sorte que ça se passe bien et un
autre et dernier point c'est que bien
sûr tout ce que je dis la surintendance
artificielle s'applique à toutes sortes
de problèmes notamment pour le futur de
l'humanité où il ya des risques
c'est important de parler des risques
mais est ce qu'il faut faire peur avec
ces risques c'est une fois question et
j'espère que dans cette vidéo ça vous
donne quelques billes pour mieux
réfléchir à ces questions tu as et des
questions que je trouve vraiment
intéressante et qui réfléchir